[Music]
they have heard something in the water
they seek care for the combination
stolen march on your indecision and the
first fool was laughter just to quell
the under fended they seek to murder
your opinion and the light has been
turned out on the age of reason replaced
by binding fires the perm wanna cross
the future for the wrong food the good
master stand idly by so I need you more
than ever I need your hand in this
resistance if we call it go the distance
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts are
brilliant guests this week is an actor
and singer songwriter Laurence Fox
welcome to trigonometry hi guys thank
you so much for having me on well we
just played a little bit of your of your
single has just come out with your album
but before we get into talking about
what it is that you're talking about and
some of those things just tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has brought you to the chair that
you're sitting in that right well my I'm
Laurence Fox obviously and I am an actor
and about when did I start about 2010 I
started writing songs and recording them
and they people liked them so they ended
up getting release and all that stuff
and now I end up on my third musical
project now which I'm just about to
release and I've been watching you guys
on on the Internet well there's a mutual
respect happening here which is always
great when it happens but actually
before I asked about your single I was
gonna say I did a little bit of research
and I get the sense that you're a
lifelong rebel is that is that fair
enough Anjali we were raised I you know
a family
were raised not to take on board what
anybody else said you know we were
encouraged to resolve our own conflicts
between ourselves and also to be to be
free and not thought and that I think
now is bordering on it's like yeah it's
rebellious I don't like being told what
to do yeah then I did go to a boarding
school for a long time and that doesn't
help no with that condition yeah yeah
welcome home brother this is the home of
rebel so let's let's talk about your
single because you sent it to me before
it came out and I was just sitting there
playing on repeat for about an hour
because I was so touched by it and it is
genuinely like what art in my opinion
should be which is where not only are
you entertaining and making good music
but you're actually saying something so
I just want to read everybody a few
lines from your single now they put
something in the water they seek a cure
for the conversation they stole a march
on you in decision and the first default
was laughter just to quell that and
offended they seek to murder your
opinions and the light has been turned
down on the age of reason I should what
are you what are you talking about
Lawrence I think I was sat in there what
used to be called the trailer but is now
a hutch as an actor upon set last year
filming something common what it was
probably Victoria or something like that
and there was this old Barney going on
outside about Kavanagh been having our
hearings and the girls were very much of
the opinion that you know you gotta
believe her and he's got to go to jail
straight away and all of that knows that
the game what do we not do the burden of
proof and you know they innocent till
proven guilty things called Twitter now
really bother me and then I decided to
become quite obsessed with American
politics because I was so bored of the
b-word and I just thought thinking I
don't think the same as any of these
people and then I thought okay so
there's a right opinion you have to have
the right opinion and the right opinion
is Brett Kavanaugh is a rapist who needs
to be struck off and not pop a
gangrenous apparently I absolutely and
you know brexit is terrible and if only
we'd known what we were voting for
everything would be fine that sort of
thing and I start going oh I don't write
a billion which bothered me and then I
thought it's very hard if you try and
express what you want to say
however reasonable or unreasonable it is
there is a there was a group of people
who will shut you down immediately
and that made me slightly terrified
because it you know stuff like reason
and I didn't know what you know again
these terribly racist things like the
Enlightenment values you know being cast
aside and straighten away and I just
found it scary and then I'm a dad so you
know my kids come and shovel it at me
sometimes as well and I'm sort of going
okay I need to document this how I feel
about it and bringing together the
thought of presenting quite a negative
position which is you know the world's
[ __ ] which is how it feels a bit at
the moment but also saying that you can
get through that ever you if you find
somebody and all other people that you
know you can do it together with I think
is what I was trying to do and you said
that you've got you feel like you're the
only one a sense in your industry but
isn't it don't you think like a lot of
people probably in your industry feel
the same way it's just they just worried
that if they come out and say these
things so their commercial opportunities
their chance to progress is going to be
curtailed yeah I mean it's it's I think
it's very difficult isn't it as in our
industry we well we're all you know
actors especially and well the comedian
so well and anyone any artists feel that
they are quite important in some way
don't they but with this sort of death
of religion and all of those things and
this people becoming kind of a religion
of one it's like what I think and my
feelings and my compassion are so
important
that if you don't agree with me then my
God smites you because you're there you
know you're the sinner is really
difficult so for me I imagine lots of
people think the same way as I do but
people just keep their mouths shut
because they don't that very small and
very vocal minority of people come in
and give you a loaded chip if you don't
say the right thing which is kind of I
mean I hate to bandy the word around a
little bit well this is an interesting
thing that I think expressing some of
these opinions as you are doing and as
we try to create a space for people to
do it allows other people to look at
that and go oh maybe maybe I can say
what I think now maybe it's okay maybe
there's other people like me and that's
why it's so great that you've come up
from the music industry and we're going
to be talking to people from like
fashion world like this is everywhere
it's not just comedy it's not just music
it's not just politics
it is literally everywhere well you sort
of opened up a chasm has been Twitter
probably as much as possible and I think
I'm Douglas Murray saying that it's it
slightly started after the financial
crisis but there definitely this we
start to see that there are two opinions
in conflict with one another and what
they call the left and the right but
what I call the sensible in the mad
people you know that people that want to
have a have a conversation so and you
mentioned that your your son is bringing
some of the stuff home from school yeah
I mean they've start them early don't
they and it sort of starts for the kind
of gentle insistent fear I went to watch
him in a football match and they were we
were encouraged not to clap when he
scored or well he didn't score because
he was in defense but his mate scored
and I was like you know and then the PE
teacher was a bit like you know we don't
do that and I said what's your opinion
on this and he said well it's actually
not that many people that insist on a
lack of competitiveness but they're very
vocal about it so you're sort of left
going what what do I do and then my son
was try and say things to me like what
doesn't matter winning doesn't matter
and I'll be like ok let's play FIFA and
I go from dad FIFA to dad fees
and I and then he gets very confused and
upset and he's you know I think it can
being caught in conflict with their own
competitiveness they say there's nothing
wrong with being a bit competitive you
know competitiveness is good because
[ __ ] one child will become good at
something another trouble want to raise
their game and then often the other
child goes ahead and then your child
needs to catch up and it's kind of a
good thing but we've sort of rewriting
the entire rule book of life for some
pretty untested theories seemingly to me
and once in my mind it completely
contradictory to what I actually think
and how I raise my kids for example and
was a tipping moment for you where you
just saw I can't shut up any longer I
think probably with I think it must have
been when I went once there John
Peterson and that the trans debate
started you know and then also had a
friend who went to Oxford and she
started saying some things to me which I
thought was like well why do I have to
think that and she and it was the
insistence it wasn't like we could talk
and disagree and come to a you know
compromise in a situation it was the
insistency if I didn't agree with her I
was 100% evil essentially and needed
educating and now I find that
frightening and it reminded me of
history class at school and communists
you know and that which apparently they
didn't teach at school anymore
you mentioned left and right and I
wonder how how much that applies anymore
because you know Frances and I he's old
school left I'm very much in the center
I know lots of people on the Left who
are as concerned about some of this
stuff I think left and right is more a
conversation about your economic views
about economic policy what I think
unites people like us and a lot of the
people who watch the show isn't where
they're coming at from Italy vote Labour
or do they vote or E or Democrats or
Republicans it's much more about are you
on board with this work [ __ ] more you
know and I think that's probably where
I'm what I'm feeling from you is you are
fed up of having that ran down your
throat yeah I am fed up a bit because I
think you must express your thoughts to
other people and they must be free to
express them back and that's how you
have who was it that was saying you know
the
where democracy works is that the lose
house to accept that it was rot little
was there the loser has to accept that
the winner won and we're now living in
this in it is a religion it and or and
have sort of cult I find it terrifying I
think it's really wrong to not allow
people to express themselves freely
because it's the beginning of the end if
you don't do that
what about this idea that it's hate
speech and it's inciting violence and if
we talk about you know diversity or any
of these kind of things that are part of
this new religion and we say the wrong
thing well that makes people feel unsafe
and uncomfortable and all this is the
counter-argument that something grow a
pair of nasty things said to me a lot of
nasty things done to me I've done a lot
of nice things people notice things I
regret but we're a process right all of
us were a process and we can't be
categorized in the instant in the moment
where we're a product of things and a
product of our thoughts and our and our
feelings
we're not just you know an identity
Rhian you're this you're that therefore
your opinion works like that I can't
tolerate it so I'm now intolerant I'm
intolerant of it which I suppose is is
where the problem is because it comes
from a place of compassion doesn't it
the whole work thing comes from a place
of compassion understanding you know
this sort of intersections of people so
you have to be very compassion but
compassionate compassion is very brutal
if applied through human context I
imagine I think it's like it's a it's a
dangerous thing because in the service
of being compassionate anything goes
even the shutting up of people deemed to
be non compassionate and therefore hate
speech and things like that it's it's
convoluted it's not truthful so you know
what hate speech is hate speech is an
incitement to violence that's why a
speeches and it's rightly legalized
again it's legislative the games but you
know calling someone a [ __ ] it's sort of
happening with football as well now and
you know at while you while you totally
want to stamp out racism in football and
it's a horrible thing you get you would
believe that every single person who
goes watch a football game
is a very little racist and I was taken
to plough Lane constantly by my dad when
we were a kid and there was some racist
things said but they were also a huge
number of families there and there
wasn't you know there was a lot of just
football fans there and you slightly get
the feeling now when you look at the
papers it's like yes we need to stamp
out racism in football how wonderful and
brilliant it was that the English and
football team made their stand last week
but also you slightly get the other side
of that coin which is all the guys that
watch football the racists you just
slightly get that feeling do you got
that feeling at all yeah I do I get the
feeling that someday a lot of the times
what we do is we demonize a working
class yeah yeah and you know for
instance things like breaks it this
stupid you know what they voted for they
fix their racist the same with football
yeah and actually a large part of
football is calling an opposition Pryor
who is a young millionaire a [ __ ] and
use they should be encouraged
generalized in their life these
Frenchie's query takes out the rear gin
a lot you know that's what we had okay
is that hate speech well it is now I
mean it's funny to write it it works
that's the most important thing as long
as it's racism or homophobia rhymes
that's it I mean we're joking of course
but when you talk about demonizing
groups of people I think that's really
what I feel that we're talking about now
is like we seem to live in a society
that is according to these people and
this ideology has never been worse yeah
there's never been more racist it has
never been more homophobic there has
never been more intolerance when we know
statistically speaking it's actually the
opposite it has never been as good as it
is now yeah it's exactly right it's it's
I think Douglas Murray is right when he
says you know it was all looking pretty
good and then the Train just went off
down the tracks and went mad I need to
sit with them girls that I know you know
me being younger the girl often be sort
of you know the patriarch he's really
done them in and there's a lot of things
block
their progress that aren't about them
boys and girls you know you're sort of
going why are you generating a victim
mentality for these people what's the
point why wouldn't you encourage
somebody that to overcome their
obstacles rather than go
you know what's the patriarchy isn't it
there's only nine point six percent of
directors of females and I'm like but
it's going up right it's not going down
there wasn't fifty percent female
directors and it's now nine point six it
was there and we're going there so why
what's the problem
yeah we can get there better quicker and
faster but you're not we're not living
in the world full of people that hate
and abuse and all that and actually fact
the only hate and abuse I'm encountering
is when I say something like that to
someone like that no absolutely and
where do you stand on the whole sort of
Hollywood whitewashing because that has
been something that we've talked about a
lot and you know characters are
originally ethnic minority oh no I think
minority a different race and then some
of you get a white person playing them
for example Tilda Swinton yeah in Doctor
Strange do you think that's a real
problem with in Hollywood are we
starting to tackle it more I think that
you've obviously I mean I don't know
because it's called acting isn't it
right yes so basically it's the clue is
in the word so Tilda Swinton can play
whatever she wants to play Jack
Whitehall can play a gay guy I don't we
aren't just played a Mancunian and I
said to another friend of mine I'm
playing monkey Niemann why didn't they
get a monkey nyan to play it and I was
like was because it's called acting
that's why it is I didn't know I think
Hollywood probably has been sort of run
by the kind of you know there is it but
America's a largely white country right
you know so you're making a product for
the to the consumer and as that changes
as the demographic changes then you get
different sorts of films but I think
just a wet racially aware is that is can
be a very difficult thing to cope with
because you suddenly are doing that old
thing about going where are you from not
can you act I think it's more important
that the being at identitarian about
things is dangerous because she's
talking I wonder why they heard that
black actor or I wonder why they heard
that white actor and it's like
well who cares what color they are I
think we weren't much more colorblind
actually in in the past than we are now
because you know again Twitter everyone
just rages the minute anything happens
and it's it's mobbing isn't it and it's
sort of like stop it you're ruining fun
for me and I'm sure I'll get nailed for
it as well because I'll someone will
come when they see me in my new job
hence the stupid hair they'll go and why
didn't they get a there's plenty of
working-class actors who are better at
doing that and I'm like yeah but at the
end of the day did they want me to do it
was i convincing in my own issue if they
don't give me the job and then they go
down the identity pathway and they give
it to them personally like the second
best who is from Manchester then no one
wins I lose out on paying my kids
ridiculously large school fees he walks
into the job going on I was second
choice and what I mean Scarlett
Johansson is someone who's had a
phenomenal amount of abuse online you
know I can play whoever I want I want to
give up on a player trans character
player trans character and the level of
abuse that she's been directed at
actually I think she apologized didn't
she she apologized never apologizing
huge mistakes why you've got so many
powerful you've got all of the Trump
ease and them and the Boris's because
they don't apologize they double down
every time and you know that's sad that
you're growing up in the world by the
only way you're encouraged to thrive is
by saying I'm not gonna apologize I'm
not taking any responsibility for it
[ __ ] you so but that's the way of
dealing with that I would that would be
my way of doing it see this is where the
problem comes in because you're talking
about progressing as a human being we're
all a work in progress we're all
evolving but you can't evolve if you
never accept your own mistakes and if
you and but you can't accept your
mistakes in public because if you do
that's it you're over so we the lack of
forgiveness is what creates this thing
where the only people who can thrive in
this environment are people like Donald
Trump and Boris Johnson who Double Down
as you say right is it a problem that we
don't seem to do forgiven us anymore
well I was raised in a very Christian
household and I really rebelled against
it so I turn up to my mom and dad's
Bible studies mash
and walking like young and I was very
rebellious but actually we were raised
with his constant idea of the fact that
there was repentance and there was
forgiveness but that was done you know
through prayer and these things and
actually I mean I don't know where I say
in my faith nowadays but I certainly
believe that at the very least that's 40
50 thousand years worth of stories being
passed generation to generation about
what is going to keep a society K he
said them stop people massacring each
other and that's crucial but now there
is no forgiveness we're screwed and and
Douglas Murray again is right when he
says you know you go you're going around
in these circles of theology but there's
no out so you can't get out the true
forgiveness so what happens is the
judgment and all of that just escalates
and escalates and escalates it's awful
and people are terrified of doing
anything so now you know you've got your
you end up with this vast hypocrisy that
we all have to put up with from you know
Prince Harry to and you know that guy on
the top of the train at cunning town you
know lecturing someone in his
middle-class way lecturing a bunch of
people who want to get to work on an
electric train and feeling justified to
do it and not you know that your
everyday person sits down goes I'm not
going to engage with this [ __ ] because
it's crazy well as if London Transport
the place to do it as well is not
Canning Town I mean if you want to fight
that's a great place to do it but you
can tell the person who decided to do
that had never been to camp
yeah I know and you know the going in
heal so yeah they'll be on board yeah I
got out of I see on Instagram and stuff
pictures of my mates ish going walking
through the extinction rebellion things
and I'm like dude you've just got back
from Lyme Regis your second house in
your G 63 AMG
so you killed 50 penguins just getting
here problematic penguins spirit
penguins but what do you think about the
hypocrisy elements on it because people
always say to you you know well you
don't like you know there's what you see
in yourself but I don't think I am I
mean we're all massively hypocritical
but why do we tolerate the hypocrisy why
do we do it why do we just go okay fine
I think it's some way it's a weaponized
virtue isn't it it's it's like what you
were talking about in enacting Wheldon
in the music world if you are not seen
as being compassionate to the victims of
Brett Cavanaugh then you automatically
evil so you have to get on the right
side because it's the right side they're
not victims they're alleged victims
right this is it I mean surely that's
the whole point of and having personally
been through a situation where I've been
accused of something well I was really
grateful for the court system to examine
it properly but it's like you can't call
someone a victim it's an alleged victim
and the way that the language is just
being driven in that in that way you
know just even known to all the stuff
the BBC say about brexit and it's just
like stop telling me about crashing out
you don't know what's can happen I don't
know what's gonna happen no one knows
what's going to happen probably not much
it won't be the end of the world coming
move on now but this with being
weaponized words being weaponized and
we're being you know it's a thing it's
right or wrong it's not right left it's
right or wrong I suppose or left or not
[Laughter]
I preferred so space for the white race
[Laughter]
people look to me and when that sounds
really bad in your accent but I think
part of the reason is I in fact I think
98% of the reason is the fact that we
always act within our own interests and
we always protect ourselves and we think
to ourselves if I stand out and if I say
I disagree this how is this going to
impact upon me and then when you look at
someone you know you know someone tweets
something and then they lose commercial
opportunities especially within your
industry when I heard you wanted to do
this my first initial well what my first
thought was really [ __ ] nuts yeah I
think it is hypocritical to believe what
I believe and not say it yeah that's how
I did Sarah in my own war in hypocrisy
but I was you know you have to it's
important I think a lot of people think
this way which is just if the desperate
need for us to talk again and not to
destroy each other
most people want just to keep their head
down and just have a life that is
essentially is free from conflict as
possible I think that's why so you know
it's like it's like when you're with
your children and what do you got two
options you can scream with them or
negotiate with them you know obviously
you want to keep you want to keep things
but when it's impacting on your life do
you not I mean and you're being accused
of things that you're you know not
guilty of for example not that I mean I
don't have an opinion I'm sort of like
most of people generally I just don't
have an opinion I didn't really have an
opinion on brexit or anything like that
I was like well if that's what you want
to do go for it
but then my opinion postbox it has
become very strong I don't know I think
it's I don't want to I think yeah people
want a quiet life but people also want
an authentic life and we're depriving
people of an authentic life by depriving
them of Daryl dentists it a that's such
a good point
it's such a good point because I think
Francis is right you
right that most people want to have an
easy life they've got kids to feed and
work to go to with extinction rebellions
and whatever else right but people have
those things but equally no one wants to
feel that they live in a world where
they're not allowed to say things that
they believe that are not bad things to
believe that a reasonable views about
the world and this is kind of where I
think we are now with that you say most
people think this they do the majority
of the country here in America around
the West absolutely do not buy into this
work [ __ ] it is a tyranny of a
minority mmm it is a tyranny of the
minority where does it come from
it's I my feeling is it comes from the
death of God and it's big you know I
pray with my kids every night for
example I just do when we because I find
it easier to go with them if they've had
a bad dream or something I find it
easier to go dear God please will you
look after my anxious thoughts and give
them back to me in the morning whatever
just to pray it out away from ourselves
rather than go here's a dreamcatcher
deal with it you know you're you know
you you can be answered for your bad
dreams is within you it's like no you
can go you can reach out with it more
and I think that we need that as people
we need to look is that great line in
interstellar when he says you know we
all spend a lot of time looking at the
ground nowadays and no one looks at the
stars we're born to look outwards and
and believe and have some spirituality
about that and you know the people that
suffer a lot nowadays seem to have
nothing they they're constantly being
told the answers within you the answers
within you but it isn't always it's
between us you know there's a good bit
in the Bible actually I'm sound like a
total religious freak but there's a good
bit in the Bible where it says that God
is there in gatherings of more than two
I think so it's like you know that it
sits in the middle between two people
rather than you know I'm right you're
right there's something beyond us where
we have to reach out and fill the void
fill that gap with you know our where
where we don't understand where we
listen to others do you think part of it
is guilt as well that we know that we've
got it good and you know that we're very
where we live very comfortable lives
compared to the vast majority of people
that's quite interesting a guilt we had
to invent something to be [ __ ] off
about yeah yeah my brother just got back
from them
Palestine and is it Palestine I don't it
is Israel when whoever runs that part
world and I said how was the Japanese he
said he was so lucky where we lived loss
he said were so lucky were a believer
and I do I often find it interesting
when you knew you hang out with the
young feminists you say you do say you
know you can always get over to the to
Saudi Arabia and have a little protest
there if you want to but no just really
difficult cuz the patriarchy is too hard
here that needs needs smashing here
first and then we'll move on to China in
the Middle East afterwards but it's like
a computer game you've got to do level
one first because there's quite a lot of
sensible substrate like we don't want to
invade other people's cultures with our
own opinion so no I think it's wrong to
turn up and have you know Boris's
opinions on what's whether someone
should what they shouldn't shouldn't
where so I think it is good not to try
and colonial eyes things but it happened
now so what are we gonna do we are we
gonna shoot ourselves down for the sins
of our forebears I don't know what do
you think well this is a kind of sins of
the father [ __ ] really isn't it and
and the thing that I I think the reason
we do the show is that both of us have
an experience of life outside the
comfortable privileged West yeah I grew
up in Russia
Francis spent quite a lot of time in
Venezuela once you've seen a bit more of
the world you kind of get a sense that
number one this is quite an unusual
thing that we have here but the other
thing about it is what you think that if
if this country hadn't done so well
historically you think the people that
we beat in that competition in that race
for success you think they would have
done things differently you think that
let's say the Muslim world if it hadn't
retreated back to its borders and
continued to expand through our medieval
Europe you think they wouldn't have had
slaves yeah you think they wouldn't have
done that I mean it's just a fact that
we were successful Western
triumphed in the battle of civilizations
why should you feel guilty about
something that people seven generations
behind you did there is that concept if
when someone does something wrong you
know say someone attacks my brother in
the street in this cars his face or
whatever then you know it's just and
right that myself and the rest of my
family should be upset and angry about
it but five generations on it's just
spiteful isn't it if my great great
great grandson is still really pissed
off that my brother got attacked his
despiteful forgiveness is a cycle of
time as well so there's kind of sudden
deliverance of all of our history in one
fell swoop you know you've got kids
protesting well young students trying to
take down statues and sussel roads and
all that stuff it's like why is that
your job to do that because you know if
you're not careful in a few generations
that be putting him back up and you're
stringing you lot up it's intolerant in
its vile I think and do you not think as
well
activism is part of the fact that they
want to achieve these small goals
because in a sense again this achievable
was big things like for instance the
housing crisis or whatever else there's
for young people there's a sense of
hopelessness around it well isn't there
isn't there a good isn't a Jewish story
about the guy goes to the rabbi and this
is one changed the world and it goes
good luck and all that and he can't
change as well and he goes back and says
we'll try and change the town and then
he all that goes back to try and change
yourself or try and least work on
yourself definitely but that that's a
personal responsibility thing and we're
not encouraged in personal
responsibility wearing cut we're told
now that we live in a vile horrible
patriarchal system run by oppressive
white men and we need to overload the
whole thing in by five minutes and I'm
like okay this might not end well guys
just to let you know my show all well
that ends well which I advertised
earlier the Bill Murray that is now very
close to selling out so we've had to
open up another day I will be doing it
again with Francis M seeing again on the
24th of November the links in the
description I'm also coming to Cambridge
in in November as well so check that out
absolutely
please come down it's going to
great show when I'm on and then when
Constantine's on you just enjoy the
interval there is no interval by the way
so it's just the mean Francis will see
that now here's a question for you so
how much responsibility does Hollywood
have to take because they are I wouldn't
even scene say me B they are eyeball
deep in this [ __ ] well the irony is
foremost I mean look this is a
controversial thing to say but I think
most male actors would understand it is
most guys get into acting to do sex
scenes with girls I think is that why
you wanted to be an actor no I love the
craft and the Hollywood is mired in
casting couch and you know like in
theater there's a whole thing about
touring when you got landlady does learn
lady's daughter does is LD DS you know
in the bottom of guest books and stuff
the whole thing is about shacking at the
end of the day and now Hollywood just
tried to go no it's not because you know
it's been it's been outed but I think
we're guilty I do know you like you
watch the films it like watch Walter
Mitty
and something like that the original
Walter Mitty and all that and see how
powerful and strong those female
characters are and how you you get a
sort of sense of what the culture was
like and now watch a Hollywood film of
which I find it quite tricky unless you
know I'm dragged to watch one and none
of it has any chemistry you're really
lacking chemistry because everyone's
sort of stuck in it kind of know this is
as the woman in this I'm going to be
like this and as the man in this I'm
going to be like this people are
constantly trying to second-guess
themselves
I think films are better when they're
you know when they're made by talented
people who aren't trying to make a point
or they're trying to make a decent
political point like the Joker or
something like that which is the film
that last time I could be bothered to
watch did you watch it
yeah what do you think of it I'm
stunning brilliant movie but so nice to
most interesting is the response to it
from the Twitter
going there auntie fire or their desks
or their that and it's like no it's just
a story and it's beautifully told an
extremely dark and they're bringing
fairy tales up and giving them to adults
you know it makes Michael Keaton's
Batman may not age that well I don't
think it has aged that well has it so
you know it's just become an adult adult
based thing
yeah Hollywood's hypocritical oh
absolutely I mean it started off with
orgies in Greece didn't it that's how it
all started the theater people banging
each other in the industry between post
me to and preemie - was it like a
sizeable change it depends on the person
when I do when I do sex scenes or
anything with somebody I'm just out of
pure natural like politeness generally I
know what are you cool with there so you
know what what is anything you don't
want to do when we talk it through
because it's also a deeply unsexy thing
today we're sexy weirdly
but now you get an intimacy coordinator
what's that if you ever see a sex scene
you get an intimacy cool what do they do
they coordinate your intimacy how do
they do that they they talk you through
it I mean
[Laughter]
that's a tricky thing isn't it you know
intimacy is a tricky thing how do you
get qualified to be I'd love it Russian
you must have for three minutes
so so that is it and that I presume is
done legally so that if there is any
pushback on the street and I go hang on
we hide this particular person and then
everything was everything went fine but
what also where is that where does the
where's the barrier between I mean
obviously but like I'm saying it was
very easy for me to work with a woman or
in some cases a man and do intimacy
enough because I'm like you were right
with them okay you know and you chat it
through and then it's not shock but if
you've got I don't know you credible so
you want a bit of a free song even in
even if it's pretend because otherwise
you'll just spot it it'll look very
mechanical we don't know that's the
problem I think we just don't know how
there's obviously a problem between men
and women and how we are engaging I
don't happen to think it's all men I
think it's probably a small minority of
men like most things that there's a
small minority of a very nasty women who
do their bit that we're allowing the
minority to dominate their general
conversation by trying to obliterate
everything and normalize everything and
turn everything into OneNote so that we
all we're all the same it's it's
equality of outcome isn't it that's what
they're after
well you need just a balance thank you
probably is important to say that people
are Harvey Weinstein what they're
alleged to have done is horrific yeah
and none of us would condone that and I
think it's fair to say that has been a
problem in that environment where you
have these massive power disparities and
lots of people want to be actors just
like lots of people want to be comedians
and if there is beautiful women and
powerful men and the power disparity
that will often result in that kind of
situation but again as you say it's a
minority you also you know I I I know
somebody who's been in that situation
and they knew exactly what was happening
really quickly and they got out of it
you know
so it's horrific and it's totally wrong
and I hope anyone who does that their
full weight of the law comes down right
on top of them but again there are
people that aren't doing that there are
you know that there is a chemistry
between people you know you do you have
chemistry between people all the time
and we're trying to obliterate that and
I think it's bad and I'll obviously be
shot down for saying that because it
just makes sense made the more you get
shot down in this interview the better
as well one thing always again why does
it surprise me it's Hollywood but just
the sheer hypocrisy of going back to the
Weinstein situation where you have all
these people coming out and going what
you did was discussing an awful and of
course it is and it was but then you saw
the pictures of them in the awards
ceremonies big Placid grins on their
faces arms around and you're like you're
telling me you didn't know there are two
years ago but now you've suddenly and
God forbid are there people that have
condemned people like that and quietly
got where they wanted to get you know do
those people exist they have have you
know kept themselves quite quiet and
climb the ladder that way I'm just
certain there are you know in the same
way it is it's it's the is the
invisibility is notice they're kind of
impunity people up to their own
ridiculousness
but showbiz is particularly bad that way
you know but it all forms of elitism is
bad that way you know it's some
ridiculous watching Harry you have a
little sob about his um you know only
having to have two kids and how awful it
is venues and you start thinking hang on
a minute this is about people going on
holiday on easyJet isn't it that's what
it's about so that you're there they're
ruining your view from your nice hotel
that you can afford that's what it is
it's not so much that you want to save
the climate it's that you don't want
other people to be able to have what you
can have and that's what bothers me and
I think it's the same with with them you
know Hollywood people saying it was
appalling it's appalling it's appalling
but of course I was his friend but I
didn't know then you know me so yeah
did any of you know I'm reading a book
which I mentioned to you about a guy who
used to be on the far-right and is now
fighting the far-right and one of the
things he talks about is that he
believes one of the radicalizing
elements that is really driving people
into the young men into the far-right is
a sense that men are under attack in
society and you you've alluded to
elements of that is that something that
resonates with you I mean I watch
Hollywood movies or even adverts and
it's just relentless from what I can see
well it's this idea that masculinity is
bad and in some way toxic and it's like
no it's a it's not about gender the
toxicity and bad babe it's got nothing
to do with gender so why we suddenly
dude the why attack men you know
especially men died in you know the sort
of gender death gap in war is pretty
terrific isn't it you know and men have
a have a place and the problem is also
like anything if you if you stop men
being then what will happen is it'll
just go underground and then when men
come back they will come back waving
their Nazi banners and their Charlotte's
film madness you know you had you I
think it's I celebrate in my own kids
much to the chagrin of almost everybody
you know your boys it's good you know if
you want to win win I mean you've I
don't know why we want to attack it I
think because we don't fit into the
system properly if you've got
competitive men if you've got men that
want to protect women for example you
know you take that away I notice my
Instagram threw up her Gillette advert
recently they've changed but a good good
combination between a man and woman or a
man a man or whatever it is you know
that we have nowadays but a good
relationship is in an empowering
relationship where you where you empower
the other person you draw out their
skills you know if there's a fire in my
mum and dad's house I would go to my mum
does not say they're better or worse
than anything but with yeah we're trying
to squash boys I think they're squash
boys in schools don't name you know
suicide is pretty dreadful and within
men
I know a lot of men that are really
suffering and then I saw em Julia
what's-her-name from veep who I really
respect the other day talking about you
know men having so much more rights than
women and we're talking about imaginary
rights in your head or are we talking
about actual rights because you have to
tell me what those are because there's a
lot of young people that support you and
basically you're teaching them to be
victims and why would you do that that
point you made is really important where
it's not about the facts it's about the
narrative yeah and we have to adhere to
their narrative because if we stray away
from the narrative we become problem
after your men's rights activist Lilly
meninist I haven't any more men in this
jumper to thing one so no they were like
you a meninist I'm like no my friend
gave it to me cause he thinks I'm a [ __ ]
I don't know why we do it why do we do
it
what's the point why do we need to shut
men up especially being a what is
perceived this it's very clear but
really to turn around because you make
it about race and gender you're
automatically on the backfoot
just by the color of your skin and what
you've got between your legs
you're already apologizing which is a
really bad place to be
why would you want to do that it doesn't
happen in white house well the other
thing with men as well as if you want
men to be better you need to give them
positive role models instead of
criticizing them and making them look
like idiots which is what all the
advertising person which is what a lot
of these movie Stuart's I would Gillette
you've brought up to lately
they didn't go he is a positive way for
a man to be they just went men do this
men do that men to that manner but and
then you get a girl I've had this I've
had a big falling out with a guy who
said do you need to be told this stuff
and I'm like what do I tell you to do
like do we sit down and I tell you what
to do you know it's not your job to tell
me what I'm not him you're stereotyping
men too but it's amazing because someone
would have sat down in a meeting in gone
this is my idea and it's really good and
they would have gone brilliant great and
then they would have shot the video in
everyone's like brilliant this one yes
and you know aren't we progressive and
then they would have got their profit
reports and gone you've told us this was
gonna work yeah and then it's like back
to guys in with their tops off with
slightly nice bodies shaving in the sea
it's what I was raised on yeah yeah you
gave us something to aspire to
yeah but the thing is about agility but
that I found very funny is that it
talked about toxic masculinity and it
showed bullying and I was a teacher for
11 years and my girlfriend went to an
all-girls school and I remember I was
sure my girlfriend the advert she was
just so what we did at girls school is
it's 3 billion times worse than that
because what we did was we went we
didn't beat someone up we destroyed them
from the inside
yeah just like dry rot and dragging them
down am i okay yeah that's what you're
made you're made by your experiences you
know unsure I've bully people in my life
I've certainly was bullied at school but
you know it was you're a product of that
without the experience is what you want
to do just March everybody gently
through life and tell them that there's
no problems I think maybe that's half
the reason why everyone gets upset about
hate speech because no one's actually
shouted at them and told them off yeah
you know what I mean it's all right my
dad was pretty hard with us but I get on
like a house on fire with him now but
he's still my dad my sons go to me who's
scarier you or Jimbo who's my dad and I
go Jimbo and then I'm still like that
he's 80 and I'm still like you know I
just never harm in that to me no
absolutely not I don't like kids
Australian food across the table at each
other it's like no one's gonna invite
you to dinner behave sit up properly and
eat well so Oh Nazi correct
the boys need discipline well I mean I
don't think everybody needs discipline
it boys in particular because of
testosterone and all the rest of it
we're just different so what do you try
to do with there's a father of two boys
to kind of counteract some of these
things I I mean patients mainly but I've
drawn some pretty strong red lines but
then I did try I got around
my son was getting one of my son's was
getting bullied at school and I said
smack him back yeah and I said damn
piece of hound I went through this
really careful thing as I just don't
never hit someone first and he hit on
the arm it just smack him back genius I
thought best bit of daddy in the world
call from school next day debt to birds
before just after reception senseof men
are quite powerful isn't it is an
imposing thing in violence between you
and often isn't yeah you know and we
square up to each other especially when
the younger I mean I don't do it now but
it's great also that violence has become
intolerable we're very intolerant of
violence which is a great thing so if
you've got one of your mates is a bit
breezy on a Saturday night out he's now
less likely to start throwing punches
but you had you do have to moderate that
testosterone even you know even in young
kids I mean I try to make myself the
enemy to my kids so when they're getting
British I make me the enemy me the
problem not each other so if they're
coming up against something they'll be
coming up against me and they know
pretty clearly where my red lines are
which are you know behave because I like
it when they go to other people's houses
and they're nice and I'd go around and
I'll see some friends and I go god your
kids are doing so well isn't it
brilliant you know and if they turn up
and they're lying down at the table
throwing food games at each other I get
a bit pissed off with them to be fair
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with it
it's not child abuse though is it at the
end of the day and do you sometimes feel
there's a conflict between their what
they're being spoon-fed at school and
what you're teaching them it's almost
like you have to take out the roots
before they're really set in depends on
the school doesn't it you know you get
some schools that have I think manners
is a really really good place to start
and also you know if you're looking for
equality of you're looking for your kids
have the best chance in life the best
thing you can teach your kid is there
however clever or stupid or brilliant
old terrible they are at something the
one thing that they can be in charge of
is how they treat people
and I only have only got jobs up until
this when I'm never going to work again
from being myself and being charming and
listening and caring what other people
think genuinely and that's taught you
don't you don't accidentally become
well-mannered you you're taught it by
somebody and in my case I was taught it
by my dad and my mom and you know their
methods nowadays would probably be
seniors you know hard too hard but it
worked on me I haven't attacked someone
in years and where do you stand on
because it seems that we talk about
men's mental health more than ever and a
lot of this I think is positive my
father had depression anxiety all the
rest of it but I think how much of
constantly focusing on this sort of you
know the intersectional systems being
won't constantly checking yourself if I
say this thing is this problematic if I
say this thing I've just said were black
in the sentence should I say the word
without color also use social media
kills it my friend of mine very early on
when I don't have before I started
really annoying people which I do on a
daily basis said to me just don't tweet
anything that you wouldn't have on an
advertising holding opposite your mum's
house and I thought that's a good rule
but yes being very aware of what we're
doing all the time is is awful for all
so come on man where everyone is quite
depressed like I'm sorry I've not met a
single person that isn't depressed
scratch a couple of little bits into a
conversation and no one's going to tell
you you know what I'm just [ __ ]
thrilled I don't meet many people like
that I meet people with a lot of
problems
don't you what's your experience I mean
I've got some friends who are genuinely
quite happy but I think most people are
suffering in a lot you know or a light
run piece and says you know to two
levels removed from some quite serious
suffering so but that's something that
we can use to bring ourselves together
instead of like going well my sort of
depression is this sort of depression
mm-hmm and you're sort depressions that
sort of pressure it's like now it's the
human condition it's quite depressing we
don't have an answer to it dividing each
other is going to cause mayhem
and you know there's a fight coming at
the end of the day if we carry on doing
it I sense I think on the depression
thing I've probably never been happier
than since we started doing the show
because I feel like I have a sense of
purpose with what I'm doing and that is
incredibly important I think
particularly for men yeah particularly
for men so I think if you feel like I
think there's a lot that can be done we
had dr. Linda Papadopoulos on the show a
while back and we were talking to her
about mental health quite a bit and I
feel like we sometimes forget that the
impact of our actions on our mental
health is huge if you eat right exercise
do something you love has surround
yourself with people that you like that
you get on with the understand you and
you understand you can have interesting
empowering conversations with other
people that will have a huge impact on
your mental health best for you people
that want the best for you you know it
also comes as you get older as well and
meaning is also I think meaning is quite
important you know this other thing that
we're all talking about life doesn't
mean anything you know because that's
the byproduct of all the intersectional
postmodern thinking it's just why do
anything if it's all the massive social
constructs and it's just all it's all
bollocks well I do anything at all a
meaning is meaning you need to be
slightly you need to have these little
things like competitiveness and stuff
like that because that means something
you want to get somewhere I want to get
somewhere like you know with music for
me for example like you know if I'd
stopped every time someone said stop it
posh [ __ ] go back to acting we already
pay you to act I yeah I would have
stopped but I don't I don't know no I
have so this gives me meaning this is
what I like and I'm proud of this and it
makes me feel good because I'm
expressing myself in a song rather than
in two bottles of Jack Daniels and a
some meaningless fight down whatever you
know so it's it is important we're
getting rid of meaning we're saying
nothing means anything yeah it really
does and it's also as well it's saying
to men that in a way it's going back to
religion thing being a man being a
straight white male means that you have
original sin I did
did we do it or didn't she do it Eve Eve
did it yes she ate the Apple first yeah
so I'd like to see her better research
haven't I done it turns out was the
Bible there's a story that they were
mean what's that all about as well
because that I if I was a woman I'd be
pretty left then that was what was being
taught their kids DNA the women
attempted the man it's now that isn't it
I don't know it's confusing me on a
daily basis the meaning of finding your
way through it getting out the other
side well I think you're right about
meaning it's if you don't have something
meaningful in your life then it's gonna
be very difficult to feel happy about it
it's and your what you your meaning is
gonna be defined by imposing your power
over somebody else and your power is
defined in the levels of righteousness
that you have over other people which is
what virtue signaling is at the end of
the day which is why you can't see any
of your in epoxy so you don't understand
I need to take the private jet in order
to go there so I can learn more about
how to lecture you about having it
that's my meaning whereas you know my
meaning is I know everyone thinks actors
are loaded but my meaning is don't be a
[ __ ] to your kids as often you know
try and be as good to your kids as
possible teach them as well as you can
what you learned from your own dad and
mum and if you can take one a nice
holiday once a year twice a year and
then they just they want to get rid of
the holiday it's like no I need to go
and fight the German for the place by
the pool that's what gives you meaning
reenactment with towels
I'm very good but I actually I think
meaning is exactly where social justice
comes in because we talked about it
being a religion and you know you and I
were talking before we started the
interview human beings whatever you say
seem to have this void inside of
ourselves that can only be filled by
devoting yourself to something that is
greater than you and as you say the
moment you take religion out of it
something else is going to come and fill
that with a human say at least God is
there is at least God is a is something
that you can relate to directly yourself
that's outside of you whereas if there
is no God in your God it's dangerous I
mean we just history is littered with
people that have done that and it really
doesn't turn out well so you know given
the choice and given the option I will
pray with my kids at night and I will
believe beyond myself because it stops
me thinking you know what I can't want
to cut your head off for the listeners
is the Lawrence look the front
he's gonna slip to the team beforehand
make me sleepy but when we move from
here Lawrence we reach peak wank in the
words of Rod little as there's still
plenty more wank to go
I slightly concerned that it feels like
it feels like there's a fight coming
that's what I worry about that it feels
like people that I think there's people
jumping on top of each other in their
speech and all of that is is already
slightly pick picking for a fight I
think there's a massive disparity in
wealth which is really bad so the
combination of people living in some
pretty horrific experiences and being
demonized at the same time you know what
happens when you've when you've shat on
your parent culture for that long will
people turn around and say I've had
enough I don't know what will happen I
think there's going to be you know these
two things can't coexist as they are so
either we all talk like this and you
know I will be savaged by whatever
people want to savage me but I mean it's
in the spirit of conversation or not no
point when saying I'm right I'm just
saying we need to talk or they're you
know this very sensory authoritarian
woke system that's growing and growing
and growing and growing in it and now is
you know unacceptable if you don't hold
that belief especially in a lot of jobs
nowadays you know you're getting
implicit bias training and stuff like
that forced on people now you might find
that there when the shoe is on the other
foot that that comes kicking that's what
I percent I mean it just seems logical
to me well it's it's that eternal thing
as you either leave talk a fight yeah
right and might be belong and leave if
you can't talk that's yeah I think it
was John F Kennedy who said that those
who make a peaceful revolution
impossible will make a violent one
inevitable yeah that's so true and
that's why we do the show because well I
think to some extent you know we want to
create a space for people to talk so
that no revolution is necessary so that
things can be resolved by I mean Francis
mentioned the housing crisis it's a huge
issue it's a huge issue and
no political will to resolve it at all
yeah it was pronounced day yesterday is
their national housing crisis year yeah
no no you know these actual issues real
issues I mean as I was saying to you
earlier my best mate is a prison officer
we went to drama school together
and he really is you know he saw that
she doesn't have any money and he does
that a house you know he's screwed I'm
trying to buy a house at the moment
I've been lucky in the yes but I even
though I'm going well so you know this
identity politics thing has replaced
class the actual real issue which is
what you do with the working class and
the massive divide between rich and poor
that's just out the window now they then
he her she's it
Aziza it's just so much easier isn't it
it's like parking tickets and burglaries
I got my house was robbed and I twice in
four days and I bought CCTV after the
first one and I got the guys faces and
then with my children's iPods as they
scooted out the door but they there was
no case because there wasn't enough
evidence from there for the Crown
Prosecution Service but every single
time I go in a yellow box on in the car
I get fined it's a crime solved isn't it
yes so it's just going what's easiest
crime to solve so much easier to get
social justice everyone let's do social
justice but you know let's leave there
you know let's have more food banks and
more people living shitty lives but as
long as they get their pronouns right
we'll be fine
this Dodgers next going to lead to
something not fun I think you're right
talking about the real issues is their
only way forward yeah well there's
another way forward which we really
don't want it but you guys do that which
is what's so good and also you know I
think it's if you're going to put
yourself on the line to be shat on in
everybody else who has any sort of vague
platform for anything that people are
interested in should also put themselves
on the line to be shut on you know so
anyone who has a vague interest in me
can now know that I am also a Nazi
welcome to the third reich before we let
you go
our last question as you know always is
what's the one thing that no one is
talking about that we ought to be
talking about
I think it's men in the family court
system I think it's I think men are
getting are having a very very tough
time if they don't have money and they
can't buy very good representation I
think you know there's a lot of suicide
around it and it's a yeah it's a it's a
it's a dodgy system the family court
system because it's private and it's you
it's a tightly anonymous so you can say
whatever you want and I think men within
within the family court system in the
way that we're supported and the fact
that we need to look at and family
breakups as a 50/50 thing where we start
together at 50/50 in the best interest
of the children I'd say that's for me
the important one because people don't
talk about it they don't if you enjoyed
our conversation check out Lawrence's
album it's out now we'll play your clip
of the full clip of his single
immediately after this follow him on
Twitter and we'll put the links in below
and as always follow us we'll see you in
the weeks time or another brilliant
episode take care guys see you next week
[Music]
the conversation is done March on your
indecision
and the first fool is laughter just to
quell the unoffending they seek to
murder your opinion and the light has
been turned out on the age of reason
replaced by binding fires the firm wanna
cross the region for the wrong fool the
good Masha stand idly by so I need you
more than ever I need your hand in this
resistance if we're gonna go the
distance I want to live
[Music]
[Music]
can we are to know what you're feeling
what with all the lines that you're
reading if it's hard to say you may need
it don't be lost thinking about tomorrow
when today is what you are living make
today on new beginning the light has
been turned down on the age of reason
replaced by blinding fires the bomb were
to cross the region further on to rule
the good that's just an idly by
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I need more than ever I need your
hand in this resistance if we're going
to go the distance if I ever doubted
think about my future and if I wanted
[Music]
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media add to trigger pod and also leave
us a nice review on iTunes and spread
the word